I'm a little ways into my roughly four
hour drive to Manchester New Hampshire
where I'm going to be staying at st.
Anselm's College hosted by the Institute
for st. Anselm studies for this summer
research residency I'm pretty excited
about heading up there there's there's a
lot of old friends that I'm going to
beat up with some from st. Anselm
College some I'll see after the the
residency ends with the meta physics
colloquium which tends to attract a lot
of big thinkers from from around the
area there's kind of a stand that
standard but regular circle that that
comes to these these are colloquia I've
got a mostly interstate drive ahead of
me taking my wife's car which has over
200,000 miles on it but i just got an
oil change yesterday and so that i want
to be all right it's about a 250 mile
trip I think so I'm putting on 500 miles
all told I'll have to do a little bit of
driving around City of Manchester to get
some groceries I need to pick up a
tripod if they have a staples for my my
flip cam so i'll be doing a lot of video
recording while I'm up there
so I suppose I should talk a little bit
about why I'm going up there in the
first place they asked me last year if I
wanted to do a summer research residency
because they've got a special collection
the think it's called the Aurora
collection now after one of the
professors and they keep this collection
of works on Saint Anselm translations
other things that are germane to an some
studies in a special room of the library
which i'll be showing you later on in
this video and the Institute and the
collections work hand-in-hand so last
year it would suggest that I might come
up for a week or two weeks and just do
some research because I'm working on a
lot of projects having to do with Saint
Anselm some of which are translation
some of which are actually looked like
monographs some of which are our papers
and I couldn't I couldn't make it happen
with their schedule I had too much other
stuff going on in the summer they did as
well so we decided we would put it off
till this summer
so we decided early June would be the
best I like that in part because the
meta physics colloquium is in early June
that means that i can combine the two
trips i will actually be changing
residents a little bit of staying in one
door that has even a kitchen this first
week and then the last two days of the
residency I'll be staying in the same
dorm is all the other members of the
globe wheel so this time around I got
into some discussions with Keith
chevallier who is there they're
archivist the librarian who's in charge
of all these special collections at st.
Anselm can I get it in a discussion with
them last time that I was up there about
the possibility of putting together some
sort of expanded database of the many
articles which they have photocopied
which right now are not in circulation
because they're going to address some
copyright issues and
I figured that would actually take quite
a bit of time because they have a lot of
materials up there what they decided to
have me do instead this time around is
to actually go through all of the
dissertations and the ones that have
adequate information about them
dissertations on Saint Anselm it is that
that the State anthem institute is has
managed to procure the ones that have
sufficient information because they're
fairly recent and they have all the
metadata that we want I'm just going to
leave alone you know note that they've
got that but the older ones we're going
to see if we can track that information
down if it's listed somewhere else on
the web and if it's not there then I'm
going to read the dissertation and
actually write an abstract and enter
some keywords for it so that people
coming to the Institute who want to find
these sorts of things are able to do so
so you can look at my work there as in
part cataloging supporting the mission
of the collections which that supports
the mission of the Institute I'll also
be working for a while on some projects
of my own I've got some writing projects
to engage in one of which s do directly
with dancehall I've got a conference
coming up this this summer where i'll be
presenting a paper
the third part of my long-term study on
mercy and justice in st. Anselm's
thought this one will be about his
prayers I've done one on the Proust
loggia and one of the courteous home
loan and now I'll be doing another
prayers and eventually I plan to turn
this into a book like study so if I get
enough time set aside I'll actually be
like out lighting the chapters or myself
I've got a paper i'm working out on st.
Thomas Aquinas and his views at hangar
for a leadership conference coming up
later this month so that's that's old
material for me but it needs to be
reworked and it needs to be placed into
us in with different context and then
I'm still working on this paper on
Gabrielle Marcel and the Christian
philosophy debates so you know I'll use
their library you know they've got a lot
of Marcel works there that I can I can
skim through and find the passages then
I've read before and want it or parade
into the paper so it will be good I'm
also going to do a ton of filming I'm
taking Anselm's works the pro slogan and
the boatload unit and I'm recording all
the footage that I will need in order to
give them something like the half over
Hagel treatment where I read the text
and then I comment
the tax because those are two texts that
i particularly like and there's nobody
else has done a commentary like that on
them I'm going to do some other filming
as well I'm hoping to do some interviews
with the staff of the Institute Monty
Brown has already agreed to do an
interview with me and I'm pretty sure
kevin mcmahon will do so as well if i
can hunt him down because he's now a
administrator i'm going to try to get a
hold of the Reverend John Thornton that
addicted monk who was the the original
director of the Institute and I'm hoping
that I can also get a little bit of face
time with Dwayne Bruce was the next
director of the Institute his sense
retired when he comes back for the
metaphysics of local with an old friend
of mine and so I want to I want to do
some get some footage with these guys
what else well i mean i'll just say i'm
on my way up now and i'm pretty excited
about the prospects it's like a
week-long retreat essentially get to
spend some time just working and
thinking without having to do any
housework or take care of the dogs or
you know arrange schedules and that sort
of thing hopefully i'll get a lot of
really productive work done both for
myself and for the Institute Monte Brown
is going to meet me once I get on campus
and directly to the place that i'll be
putting all my gear and staying and then
it's it's hit the ground running i took
off at seven in the morning hoping to
arrive by 11 so i can get a full day of
work done I've got myself a stock and
food along you know sandwiches for the
day apples it's a you know
it's not a military mission type of
thing but you know I like to be prepared
by Chef text RV so I always go into
things knowing what it is that I need to
do and once I get there it's going to be
you know for the first couple days it's
going to be you know one thing after the
other in part because my work at the
library needs to get done within a
certain timeframe there on summer hours
academic libraries on campuses Wathan
will have shortened summer hours so the
library is not open at all over the
weekend so I'm losing two days because
of that of possible work in the library
and they have shortened schedules for
Thursday and Friday where they close at
four thirty I can get there and eat and
work until four thirty but that only
gives me eight hours effectively to get
into anything done if i take just a
short lunch break well now I'm
interstate 190 in Massachusetts heading
north which is going to turn into
highway 13 pretty soon of about three
hours into the trip another hour yet to
go I'm getting close to the New
Hampshire border which is good because
that's where I'm headed so I've made it
through a good portion of New York good
portion of Massachusetts and now I'm
final leg of the journey and
it's a beautiful area there's all sorts
of rock formations everything is green
you know there's still some wildflowers
and various sorts a little big that
gone out down in the Hudson Valley a
little bit of a different zone here I
decided to take this route because I
haven't gone this way very often and I
wanted something a little bit more
scenic since I had to drive this look
drive anyway and I think that was kind
of tired of interstate driving so fairly
soon this is going to turn into just ate
and I way and really looking forward to
getting there and I'll start showing you
some of the campus once I've actually
arrived we're getting close to the
college now this is actually st.
Anselm's drive and we're going to be
pulling up to the campus in just a
moment is a road I've lon driven
certainly not as often as the people who
work there of course but this been a
place that I've been to why year after
year after year now we're just coming up
to the beginning of the campus
see some of the field there's the campus
itself
and here we are st. Anselm College all
right
pulling up there's the chapel itself
library will be working and that is old
main ahead of us I'm going to go park
and then find Monty
the Institute for st. Anselm studies
that is hosting me belongs to Sigma
Anselm's college and what they've done
is put me up in one of their dorm suites
and see I've got my various reading
materials that had brought along with me
some Quietus immerse elsom he and some
my book on the Christian philosophy
debates and some digs I'm running on
that so materials on epicurean
traditions and Hegel illumise's all
articles that i have previously a
photocopied or printed out dealing with
and so on that I'm going to be using for
some of the things I'm writing there's
the typical sort of common room where I
sit and do some of my reading it's two
bedrooms rather Spartan conditions i
think by modern dorm room standards but
that's because college students tend to
be given pretty luxurious circumstances
this is that much more like what it was
like when i was in college there's
actually two bathrooms one of the shower
here's where i'm going to be sleeping
i've already up my gear stowed in the
closet and there fortunately i remember
to bring an iron because there is
literally nothing here other than the
room itself so i brought utensils it
brought all the sorts of things that I
thought I might need for the roughly
week that I'll be staying here
the department itself is within a
courtyard very nice nice to be it's also
located right next to the famous st.
Anselm Institute for politics we're
about a year well less than a year it's
going to be really hopping here given
that the primary season you'll be
beginning there you can see a little bit
of the Institute right there this is
Saint Anselm drive the road that the
college is on in Manchester
I have more or less settled into the
apartment and now I've got a little bit
of a walk through the woods on this nice
path to get to the library where I'm
going to be starting my my work for
today this is the quad over there is the
chapel and the monastery itself there's
where i'm headed the geisel library so
my task that I'm performing for the st.
Anselm Institute is to go and look at
every one of these dissertations find
out whether there's adequate information
already available about them and for
those for which there is not which I'm
guessing us both you can be quite a few
of these I'm to come up with abstracts
and key terms so I'm going to have to
first start by finding which of these
are actually in the system with plenty
of information it might appear that all
I've done is shift one stack of books
from one place to the other but actually
what I've been doing over the last two
hours is compiling a pretty extensive
database have gone through each one of
these dissertations and gotten the entry
from the geisel library's catalog put
into the spreadsheet all the relevant
things that I'm looking for the title
the name the year whether there's an
abstract available whether there's
subject keywords available and then any
sort of little notes that I needed i'm
not completely through i still have a
few more stacks to go i should push
these over here so don't forget them the
next day but the project is underway so
that is good news